[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Renault's talisman brought new elegance
to the midrange in 2016 its conspicuous
new design as an eye-catcher on the
street the chic French cars available as
a sedan or station wagon
one's had in Kabul city car testiness
paid 3 says station wagons are a long
familiar body form but that doesn't mean
they're boring
today she's testing the Taliban grand
tour which is not only some new visual
features but a real technical surprise
too The Talisman offers a choice of two
turbocharged gasoline and three turbo
diesel engines eNOS is testing the car
were the most powerful diesel which puts
out 118 kilowatts it accelerates from 0
to 100 and 9.6 seconds top speed 213
kilometers an hour the engine will as
two differently sized turbochargers
already reaches its maximum torque of
380 Newton meters at 1,750 revs The
Talisman has a six speed double clutch
transmission the nearly 4.9 meter long
station wagon is extremely maneuverable
the technical highlight is the dynamic
all-wheel steering says eNOS when you
take a curve at speeds of up to 80
kilometers an hour the rear wheels turn
in the opposite direction providing more
dynamics and agility you really see the
difference for control is the name of
the system that turns the rear wheels to
up to 3.5 degrees this shrinks the cars
turning radius by 80 centimeters to
11.30 meters the rear wheels tire tread
protrudes clearly from the wheel well
to compare here you see the moment when
the car begins moving straight ahead
again
[Music]
flowing parallel lines characterized the
talismans exterior design the daytime
running lights extend far beyond the
headlights to the bumpers a long hood
highly convex surfaces on the doors and
chrome trim on the side windows make the
car seem even longer
[Music]
the 19-inch alloy wheel rims are like
designer accessories at the rear the
expansive light design underscores the
cars with
[Music]
yeah I'm HEC Medina says the taillights
are a true high point Renault played
with light and here it almost grows
together in the middle at the moment the
only other cars with that are sporty
models like the Audi TT and the Porsche
911
the rear hatch opens at the push of a
button offering a roomy trunk but the
broad lacquered and unprotected area on
the bumper is impractical when you stow
cargo
[Music]
snazzy details and modern design are the
strengths inside
penis likes the talismans interior -
that's a large vertically arranged
display replaces a great number of
buttons among the buttons
this one here catches your eye it has a
flower with five petals each standing
for a different driving mode when
heinous press is here the lighting mood
changes along with the driving mode one
of the modes can be defined by the owner
the multi sent system with its adaptive
suspension adjustments and other
adjustment options is standard equipment
even in the basic model compared with
other cars that have ambience lighting
the colors here are very intense but
they can be dimmed down the playful
colored light contrasts with the clear
arrangement of the interior the
materials used seem very high quality
and are pleasant to the touch
[Music]
susannah penis was very pleased with the
design of the talisman grand tour but
especially with its maneuverability
which really surprised her she would
have expected it from a vehicle for
point eight six meters long
unfortunately the dynamic all-wheel
system for control is not standard
equipment but comes in a one thousand
seven hundred euro package but in
combination with the rear view camera
it's worth the price because it makes
the car much easier to handle in
everyday driving
[Music]
[Music]
seiyya
car Chester line ho Dyson over says BMWs
2 Series Coupe a runs in a competitive
back alley and Daimler have compacts
with more than 185 kilowatts of power
with a 230 eyes 2 litre 4-cylinder turbo
churns out 252 horses or nearly 188
kilowatts so is the BMW the predator or
the prey for rival Mercedes a250 sport
offers 25 kilowatts less performance but
at a price that's 2,500 euros higher and
Audi TT coupe a comes closer at a
difference of 16 kilowatts it's 500
euros cheaper than the BMW - the series
2 coupe a was already on the market in
2014 but the 230 eye we tested has only
been around since last year it can shoot
from 0 to 100 kilometres an hour and 5.6
seconds it tops out at 250 kilometers
per hour
looking at the exterior it's no wonder
the 2 Series Coupe a zips along it's
just like a 4 Series BMW and miniature
just not as flat or wide just about
everything in the engine compartment is
clad in plastic and discreetly screened
off but at least it looks tidy the hood
is long and sleek while the rear end is
cropped the 2 Series is a classic coupe
a the Mercedes 8 class doesn't have the
same flare and the TTS looks don't quite
cut it either
the shape of the taillights is
reminiscent of the x6 the interior is
just fine everything as it should be
with clean lines and classy workmanship
but the competitors from English taught
and Stuttgart can match it as a matter
of course there are plenty of dust
catching shiny surfaces in most of
today's cars a steptronic automatic
transmission adds about 2100 euros to
the 230 eyes price the fly of capiz I
know says the 2 Series takes people back
to the iconic 2002 turbo in the early
70s the two-door coupe a could keep up
with the eleven Series Porsche but then
the oil crisis knocked down the sales of
gas guzzlers the new 2 series has driver
oriented controls and a stiff suspension
and is still comfortable on long drives
and the backseat can even fit two adults
our test car has been fitted out with
the M Sport package that includes the M
sports chassis aerodynamic body styling
a leather steering wheel and sports
seats up front for an extra thirty six
hundred euros
[Music]
the BMW 230 ice competitor Mercedes a250
sport includes these sporty add-ons for
a similar standard price outies TT
features an s-line sports package in the
same price class they all sell for
around 40,000 euros though not a bargain
the buyer gets plenty of performance and
comfort for the money
for people who don't want so much form
but like the looks of the two series
Kupe there's the intro gasoline model
with a 100 kilowatt engine it sells for
just over 28,000 euros insult says the
230 I goes from zero to one hundred and
five seconds and offers more trunk space
than the VW golf the big difference
between it and the GTI is rear-wheel
drive which means more driving fun
Hospice that's something neither the
a-class Mercedes or the Audi TT offered
given that in its class the BMW 2 Series
Coupe a appears to be the hunter rather
than the hunted
[Music]
the fifth generation of the Ciotti beats
is having its world premiere in
Barcelona Ibiza has always been the
Volkswagen subsidiaries mass product so
far five point four million have been
sold 600,000 of them on the German
market alone BBC is the first car with
the MQB a platform but soon the VW Polo
and the Audi a1 will build from it as
well
Opel unveiled its crossover model
Crossland X to the world at an event in
Berlin 4.21 metres long the Crossland X
is 16 centimeters shorter than the Opel
Astra but 10 centimeters taller the new
cars trademark is a sassy two-tone
design and a relaxed SUV look unlike the
Mokka X SUV whose all-wheel drive can
take it off-road the Crossland X was
conceived for the city
[Music]
Norris Carr Chester Michelle Assenmacher
has been thinking about what a car would
need to have to be perfect for everyday
driving he came up with a list of five
important factors one is the feel-good
factor Michelle says she has to be able
to get in and feel at home and
understand it right off the bat another
is good visibility often there's very
little room to park in big cities so
it's important to be able to see all
around the car a third is spaciousness
she needs room for at least five people
the fourth is fuel economy she covers
enough kilometers per day that she
really couldn't afford a car that
guzzles fuel feels locked the fifth is a
powerful engine she doesn't need a race
car but it should have enough horsepower
to get around and she says she knows of
a car that meets all these criteria
the masta - as it's called in Germany is
a snappy little car apparently made for
city dwellers and drivers and it's
snappy for a good reason it's one and a
half litre diesel gives its super mini
220 Newton meters of torque and against
a top score for fuel economy rated at
just 3.4 litres per hundred kilometers
on average with the exclusive line
package and options like LED headlights
the car we tested lists for about 21
thousand euros
[Music]
so as far as the feelgood factor goes
Michelle felt at home the moment she got
behind the wheel maybe because she
drives a Mazda to herself all the
controls are within easy reach so she
knew where everything was right away the
six gears let you cruise along
comfortably at high speeds and low revs
rare for a supermini compact
the next factor is visibility Michelle
is going to look for a parking spot and
find out how good it really is the rear
parking sensors make it easier to fit
into tight spots but they're only
available at extra cost the 650 euro
Touring package includes rain sensing
wipers a light sensor and heated drivers
and passenger seats
[Music]
Michelle finds the parking sensors very
helpful without them she wouldn't have a
good overview of the rear because of the
wide seat pillars
[Music]
but a relatively short length under 4
meters also helps when looking for
parking spots
[Music]
monster describes their supermini as
small but big on fun
[Music]
Mazda's range of engines delivered
greater performance for lower fuel
consumption thanks to the SKYACTIV
technology
apparently the secret is the high
compression ratio
normally this would make the engine
knock but increasing the fresh air
reducing hot residual gas keeps it
running nice and smoothly
inside everything's in easy reach the
carbon fiber multifunction steering
wheel buttons give the car sporting
field the carbon fiber trim throughout
the interior succeeds in striking just
the right balance of sportiness and
practicality in comparison to other
brands the multimedia system is
extremely straightforward instead of
distracting touch controls one single
knob covers all the functions next is
the third factor spaciousness if
Michelle's taking off on a trip with a
small family will the Mazda 2 provide
enough room
[Music]
she's satisfied with a luggage space but
what about the seating comfort Michelle
has to secure the bags but she's got
enough room to accommodate luggage even
for longer trips it's all spice and all
fine and a little thought our test cars
exclusive line package also includes
tinted rear and side windows now
Michelle comes to her fourth factor
economy she's running on 5.6 liters per
hundred kilometers but she's managed to
get it down to five point two still a
far cry from the factory rated three
point four liters it's nothing unusual
to find consumption higher in practice
than the manufacturers ratings the fifth
and last factor is the powerful engine
at 77 kilowatts the Mazda 2 is nothing
to be ashamed of
but Michelle misses the acceleration on
winding roads she wants to be pushed
into the seat just a little
[Music]
so krischell sums up first for the
feelgood factor the Mazda 2 definitely
makes the grade she has enough room and
feels comfortable second visibility the
parking sensors which are not standard
equipment did the trick parking went
smoothly so she can check this one off
2/3 spaciousness all the bags fit in
just fine
so Michelle says mission accomplished
fourth is the fuel efficiency the Mazda
twos diesel engine did very well on
third final criterion is the powerful
engine she doesn't expect a sports car
fuel consumption is more important for
everyday driving than a fast engine so
she recommends the car without
reservation and gives it good marks down
the list as far as she's concerned the
Mazda 2 is a good car for everyday use
and meets all her criteria and looks
nice besides
[Music]
armies of tradesmen have spent a good
part of their lives in the driver's seat
of the very first generation of the VW
bus called simply the t1 driver
Christoph Bowers taking one of the more
than 1.8 million t1s built out for a
spin the VW bus was the right vehicle at
the right time
no insanity Christophe recalls its
history starting in 1947 as West Germany
was still rebuilding from the Second
World War
back then trades people urgently needed
a practical utility van to carry their
tools and materials from A to B despite
the massive damage at the VW planet
Wolfsburg a solution was eventually
found at the time VW workers were
carrying parts and materials with a
transporter they'd built themselves by
putting a simple flatbed on a beetle
chassis and engine the parts carrier
inspired visiting vege VW importer Ben
pond to sketch what would become the VW
bus the engineering was based entirely
on the still new beetle the only VW in
production at the time Christoph
continues in the autumn of 1948 vew
chief Heinrich Nordhoff approved the
construction of Eve Tillett Eve and
designed to carry a 750 kilogram payload
based on the dependable VW Beetle but it
was not that easy nor cheap as it
happened the Beetle chassis tended to
break up under a full load on the poor
quality roads of the time the beetles
platform chassis wasn't strong enough to
handle the one and a half tonnes of a
fully loaded transporter so VW's
engineers created a new ladder chassis
with a single unit body but the axles
engine and many other parts were still
taken from the beetle it was 1950 and
all they needed was the right name
[Music]
by the conjecture stuff explains them in
Germany the VW bus is known as the bully
a mixture of bus and leaf of Ivan or
delivery van unfortunately the name was
already trademarked and other
suggestions such as Felix you live
bollocks and triumphant or were also
shot down by the Patent Office so what
the VW bus was given the simple
designation type - but it's German fans
didn't care they still know it as the
bully today the VW bus was a hit with a
car buying public in Germany and the
world over in 1954 the 100,000th unit
came off the production line
extraditions like the Samba bus and the
practical flatbed pickup soon appeared
the highly versatile VW bus enjoyed huge
popularity Christoph this is one of the
friendliest most likeable faces in
automotive history these funny bug guys
attract lots of nostalgic looks on the
road but the bus came close to looking
quite different production would have
been a great deal cheaper for a body
with square contours but tests in the
wind tunnel showed that round edges made
for much less wind resistance so the VW
bus was in fact one of the pioneers of
aerodynamics
a split front windshield the v-shape
front panel and a gargantuan VW emblem
gave the first generation of the bus its
now iconic face a higher ground
clearance and a practical flatbed with
an optional canvas cover help make the
t1 picked up the ideal construction site
workhorse the double cab was introduced
in 1958 with space for six workers and
their tools but heavy loads still push
the engine to its limit in praise of the
legendary 1.1 litre 25 horsepower boxer
engine taken from the beetle it's no
surprise that a load of one and a half
tons had the engine puffing and groaning
so the engineers gave it a shorter gear
ratio that brought the top speed down to
80 km/h but made it more dependable as a
workhorse should be the 1.2 liter engine
in this one delivers 34 horsepower
these days the village t1 buses are
mostly retired from their labors with no
load they can be surprisingly nippy even
if the maximum speed of just 95 km/h and
the partially synchronized transmission
will keep a driver in the country very
leisurely Christoph attributes the VW
buses enormous success to its incredible
versatility the version he's driving now
is a double cab pickup or as its fans
call it
Doka and dokas were the preferred
vehicle of builders the high load sil
helps it get through rough terrain such
as foundation pits with ease down
physically powerful behind fun hold up
the house
like all the other additions the double
cab pickup was a best-seller in 1958
Volkswagen moved production from
Wolfsburg to a plant built especially
for commercial vehicles in Hannover
three years later the one millionth VW
bus rolled off the assembly line
Kristof sums up the VW bus is the
ultimate multi-purpose vehicle a
workhorse a home an ambulance lifestyle
mobile the only limits are the owners
imagination the aerodynamically
optimized body and lightweight
construction left the competition back
for dust it became one of the driving
forces of West Germany's post-war
recovery a technology innovator and
without a doubt a milestone and
automotive history back then and today
the dhoka is the cheapest way to go if
you want to drive a first generation VW
t1 the t1 buses are still treasured
collectors items as indicated by their
sharp rise in prices in recent years
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you